new in theaters this weekend the lego
movie to the second part what men want
and cold pursuit what will you see this
is your weekend ticket everything is
awesome everything was awesome was now
everything is now the lego movie - the
second part comes out this weekend this
is the fourth franchise installment and
direct sequel to the first lego movie
appropriately named the lego movie it's
been 5 years now the citizens bricksburg
have been invaded by the destructive
Duflo aliens who have left behind a mad
Maxie and wasteland of rubble after
wyldstyle is abducted M&T must save the
day
this movie is for you if you liked any
of the other lego movie movies you
prefer a hunky Chris Pratt is a tiny
lego man or you hate it when your
sibling goes in your room and touches
your stuff I think we here after last
night yeah that's what happens when
tequila meets and desperation okay stop
saying things it shouldn't be saying to
your boss holy crap can you hear my
inner thoughts what men watches in
theaters this weekend this fantasy Tommy
is a loose remake of the original what
women want that came out mm but now the
tables have turned
taraji P Hudson's character Ally a
successful sports agent gets passed up
for a promotion one thing leads to
another and she gains the ability to
read men's thoughts the lady which doing
it the big boys table huh - crap I'm
bluffing these fools I'm missing Real
Housewives check finally has a winning
head why am i thinking in the third
person this one is for you if you like
fun high concept comedies taraji P
Henson and Tracy Morgan make you laugh
or you've always wanted to be able to
read people's minds did you guys get all
that Kyle's dead tell me what happened
you got mixed up with some drug dealer
Mike you know guys
and finally cold pursuit hits the big
screen this weekend Liam Neeson plays a
snow plow driver whose son is
mysteriously murdered by drug-dealing
gang members so he takes matters into
his own hands to track down the bad guys
this one is for you if you like liam
neeson action movies you agree that cold
snowy landscapes make for the best
action revenge landscapes or you drive a
snowplow that is your weekend ticket
what will you see check back next week
for the second installment of groundhogs
day with murder
[Music]